je alors je me suis fait largo largué
par texto en pleine nuit on sait que
c'est pas isabelle scala be bop
donc je me suis fait larguer par texto
ça casse a dit ouais j'étais sûr oh je
te jure et bien castaldi ouais parce que
castaldi en pleine nuit je le vois bien
ce faire la mairie est exactement en
fait j'ai dépassé par quelle femme l'a
alors c'était non c'était c'était ma
femme et stéphane fois c'était ma femme
et ma femme en fait et ça qu'elle je ne
peux pas vous le dire mais non c'est
fanny ferrand ce cas vous interroger par
sms non plus à la décrue est oui et
aurait en fait je partais je faisais la
matinale sur une radio rtl2 l2 tu as
fait et je partais assez tôt le matin et
je revenais donc après l'émission et je
faisais une petite sieste
parce que j'étais fatigué et j'ouvre mon
téléphone et j'ai ces textes au khimki
me dit voilà c'est fini
bon on a eu des cardeurs radio ils sont
pas assez bon je te le dire voilà
incroyable des voix de femmes elle
voudrait quitter paraissait ouais ouais
c'est ouf ça fait ouf avait sans rigoler
je veux que ça ouais ouais flavie et
sans explication bon mais yahia moyabi
un dosage était pas j'étais pas
exemplaire non plus mais mais des liens
non la pression
non mais ce n'est pas le plus parfait
des marais mais c'était assez violent le
texto pour barrer bastille s'est passé
votre femme quoi donner l'eau et non non
c'était assez concis ouais ça n'est pas
bien la ccc ccc fort
je suis très fort de se faire larguer
par sa femme par sms c'était vraiment
c'était un assez beau message allure ah
ouais j'aime pas ta gueule il a gardé la
main c'est beau mais ce qu'on a vécu
cette aventure c'était mes jambes ne me
portent plus je sais qu'il prendra son
hub petits veinards
je m'en vais voter non plus